okay i think i've played
this person before yeah i've gone on a
dangerous ride
before but i felt like i felt like going
on a dangerous ride again
so that's what i'm gonna do
okay knight of six let's play some kind
of
king's indian
it is supposed to be a dangerous ride
after all you're not supposed to go e5
there dude
this is supposed to be this is supposed
to
just weaken your your center a bit too
much
let's see if he has something up his
sleeve so far
my opponent is playing fast but
i think not that well
like nothing
nothing major but at this point
i've probably equalized with
chances of more
so c5 this is this is called
overextending
to be fair
like he's a he's kind of
asking a bit too much of his position
here
yeah let me go knight c6
i mean i'm probably exaggerating like
it's not
it's not that bad for white but
still i think anybody who
plays these sort of provocative openings
with with black would be very very happy
to to have this position he goes d5
which is absolutely the best move
um and here i have some options i'm
thinking of knight b4
um then he could go queen b3
i could take on c3 bc3
then go knight e3 fe3
knight d5 rook d1 then then he has e4
but if i take a d5
first he goes rook d1 i go c6
if you go c4 i go knight e3 fe3 queen a5
check and i save the knights
um but in that
in that line you could also make other
moves to preserve the bishop
yeah whatever i talk too much about it
so i gotta go for knight b4
you can also you can also go h3 here
but i was hoping in that case that i
would take an f3 taken off three take an
e3
uh fe3 and then i would go knight a6
maybe and
try to pressure the pawn on
c5 and somehow justifying
the fact that i put this
uh put this knight on the stupid b4
square
instead of just cementing it on e5 after
exchange to knife three and e3
um
okay so what what do we do here
i think we take on three you can't take
with the queen
because of um
uh because of the fork in c2 so he has
to go gf
then i go e6 and we'll see what happens
so far i have to say that this ride is
only dangerous for my opponent
let us see what he does
i'm officially breaking opening center
well i'm fine it's got time to think
though so
yeah this is what i was hoping for now
to go with knight e3 and if if
fe3 i had queen h4
winning the bishop on c4
so that's going to be game over or
that's going to be a winning position
like i've i've blown winning positions
before
i can blow winning positions in my sleep
but this one i think i'm not gonna blow
so i go knight d3 check
i'm gonna take on b2 attacking his queen
now the knight is on c3 is undefended
which means that i
which means that i i win
another night
and
yeah that's very much game over
so it takes an f7 just take with the
rook
uh yeah whatever i'll just go bishop c3
try and be technical take back with the
knight
if he takes the queen knights can move
backwards
this is not shogi
now also e3 is hanging so
[Music]
everything is
very comfortable
rook fade and now i'm starting a
potential
potentially mating attack rook f3
is gonna is a threat with uh mate in two
king and four bishop six will be made
and he quite prudently resigned
okay